hi and welcome back to the third part
of this webinar where i give an
introduction to machine learning from an
applied perspective
specifically targeted at researchers and
practitioners of applied econometrics
who think about how to add machine
learning to the econometric toolbox
and one to understand how novel tools
based on machine learning can improve
practical empirical analysis
in the first part of this webinar
i'm motivated why looking at machine
learning is particularly interesting
specifically that machine learning is
very powerful
at solving prediction problems and that
solving such prediction problems
underlies many modern machine
intelligence tasks
in the second part of this webinar i
introduced some of the central ideas
of what makes machine learning predict
so well
in this last part i want to ask given
what machine learning does
what can we learn from its output
to recap the basics of machine learning
from the last module i
argued that machine learning is
characterized by
a combination of three features it uses
very flexible functional forms
but it limits the expressiveness in
order to avoid
excessive overfitting and it uses the
data
to resolve the trade-off specifically
it uses the data to learn how much to
regularize
and how much overfit how much
expressiveness to allow
in this part of the webinar i want to
ask
what do these specific features so what
is the fact that we
fit machine learning in this specific
way imply
for the properties of the resulting
prediction function
and how can we therefore use those
prediction functions
in applied work
to remind ourselves here is the basic
setup that we studied machine learning
in
we considered specifically supervised
learning
or prediction where we are
given a data set which is the training
data set
of some outcome variables y and then
some covariates
x as well as a loss function and our
goal is
to find a prediction function so that we
predict
why well from x with respect to that
loss function
specifically we wanted to produce
an outcome with a low expected
loss where the expectation here is
over a new sample point drawn from the
same distribution
as our training sample so now
assume we have solved that problem we
have found a prediction function it
works really well
maybe that's a regularized linear
regression like a lasso or ridge
or maybe that's a random forest or a
booster tree
what can we know learn from this
function
f hat about the truth
so specifically assume we have this
prediction function
that fits the relationship of y to
x well what can we learn about the world
from the prediction function f hat
so often we may be interested in using a
function that we have fitted to the
relationship of y to x
to make inference on the conditional
expectation of y given x
so to make inference on basically the
optimal
true relationship between the outcome y
and the covariate x
in this regression sense so that may be
particularly tempting
to do when the output has a very common
form for example when the output as
is the case in regularized linear
regression like glass or ridge
actually itself has a form of a linear
regression
so the question is to which degree can
we now use the coefficient
of that regularized linear regression in
case some
can say something about the world for
example which of the
features in the world which of the
covariates actually matter to determine
for determining the outcome
or maybe even saying something about the
causal relationship
between the x variables and the y
variable
so in typical econometrics
what we want to know about those
coefficients the kind of properties
they may for example include the
following we may want to know whether
the coefficient has bias so whether on
average it gets us to the truth
we may want to know whether the
coefficient is consistent
meaning in large samples it approximates
the true coefficient well
we may want to also be able to do
inference
meaning we may want to establish
properties like asymptotic normality
or being able to calculate standard
errors or be able to perform
tests in order to say something about
the true parameter beta
from what we learn from this data and
finally
we may want to understand how robust our
estimate is
for example whether our takeaways depend
on very specific features of the data
or whether they generalize well even if
certain assumptions aren't exactly true
to study whether we can hope to use
output for machine learning to learn
something about the world in a similar
way
to what we are used to with linear
regression i want to start with a lasso
because it produces output it looks very
similar
to remind ourselves what does the lasso
do
the lasso fits a linear regression with
the additional constraint
that the coefficients aren't allowed to
be too large that allows us
to still fit the lasso even when there
are a lot of x variables
in our regression and it allows us to
fit the
lasso in a way that balances
the expressiveness meaning the
complexity of our function
against the risk of overfitting
and so the higher the parameter lambda
is the higher the cost of complexity is
the smaller the coefficients will b and
potentially the more of them
will be zero so specifically we saw
that the lasso does not only shrink
coefficients it also selects
meaning many of the coefficients may be
zero and if there are multiple
coefficients that produce
a similar prediction prediction outcome
then the lasso may be capitalist and
that it just
chooses a winner and gives all to that
one winner
so what does that step from oles to
lasso look in an example
for that one i'm using an example where
our goal is to predict
default so say this is default
probability
and and we want to predict default
from a number of information in our data
set that would be in a typical credit
file
that may include a person's income their
age maybe
information about the education maybe
their credit score
and some other variables here i assume
there are a total of 80 of them
so what does the all what does lasso do
relative to oles
well the problem with oles is that there
may be excessive overfitting in that
using all those variables many of which
may even be close to collinear
and may lead to very unstable
and high variance coefficients that lead
to bad prediction performance the lasso
instead says
let's only use a subset of those by
putting
a penalty on coefficients that are
particularly high or in the case of the
lasso
implicitly also by coefficients with a
lot of non-zero
coefficients
so when the lasso selects those there is
a hope here
that the resulting spa solutions can
actually tell us a lot about
the variables that matter maybe for
example the lasso could be good at
telling us
which variables cause default to be
higher or lower
so to study to which degree we would be
able to do so
here is an exercise that we run in a
paper on
credit scoring specifically the fairness
of credit storing and attempts to
regulate it
so in that case what we did is we didn't
only run the lasso once
but we ran the lasso multiple times on
different subsets of the same data set
so we chose 10 random subsets of the
same data set
so the distribution of all those 10
subsets is the same
and then we ran the lasso on each of
them even holding the penalization
parameter lambda constant
and every time we checked what are the
variables that are selected by the lasso
in each of the runs here's the result
that we got
on the x-axis you see the 10 different
iterations
on the y-axis you see the coefficients
that were actually
selected what you can see here is that
there are clearly some patterns
there are some coefficients that are
persistently selected
and there are some coefficients that are
persistently not selected
so black meaning it is selected meaning
the coefficient is non-zero
so if there is a black line all the way
from the left to the right it means that
this coefficient was included in all of
the models across all the 10 runs
if on the other hand there's a white
line meaning the coefficient
is never selected then that means it was
always
set to 0 in all of those 10 iterations
but the shocking thing thing that i
think this exercise shows is that
while there may be some persistent
patterns
for many of the coefficients there is no
clear pattern visible
in the sense that many of the
coefficients are sometimes selected
and sometimes not selected so now
before we think about the implications
let's
think about what could be going on here
so what happens here so sometimes
the lasso will select some of the
coefficients
at other times it will select some other
of the coefficients
that is perplexing at first because we
may think that
a good prediction function should always
look similar given that the data in each
of those folds was basically the same
however in high dimensional data and in
many
typical data sets that we may work with
that have a very high number of
covariates
it can be the case that these covariates
are very highly correlated
and that for example age in this
regression can very well be
expressed or predicted by a combination
of other variables
now if one of those variables can very
well be predicted by a combination of
the others
then whether age is included or not
doesn't really
change much the lasso's ability to
predict because it could simply
choose some of those variables that are
highly correlated with age
include those instead and still get the
same predictive power and indeed
it turns out that depiction quality and
even the predictions themselves do not
vary too much
across those 10 draws so
what do we take away from that so if we
had really hoped
that the lasso tells us something about
which variables matter
then at least in this example in a high
dimensional case
that is probably it's probably not a
good idea to put a lot of weight on
which variables were selected by the
lasso
simply because of the fact that which
variables get selected
change so much from draw to draw
but beyond this very general statement
we can become
a little bit we can get a little bit
more
precise and study in a little bit more
detail what kind of biases can actually
happen when we think about which
variables get selected by the lasso and
what their coefficients are
so if you want to just get the general
intuition
i think the example i just went through
may already be enough but now i want to
be a little bit more precise
and look at one very specific example
and talk about the biases that can
happen here
specifically i'm assuming that there is
just three variables
x1 x2 and x3 some outcome variable y
and that the outcome variable only
depends on
x2 and x3 in a specific way
so what could happen when i fit the
lasso here
which doesn't like to include a lot of
the covariates
first of all there could be selection
biases
where if 2 and x2 and x3 are very highly
correlated
then the lasso may decide not to exclude
include x3 because x3 by itself
will not be very predictive if x2 is
already included
because if x2 and x3 are very highly
correlated
and then it may be easy to express
most of the effect of x3 by simply
using x2 and that would reduce the cost
of complexity
while not making prediction much worse
so i would call this compactification
bias
meaning the set of variables that are
actually included
are less than the variables that are in
the true model and they are
in this case a subset so i'm only
including x2 despite
x3 also mattering and the true model
but they can also be the opposite thing
they can be expansion bias it can even
be
that a variable gets included in the
lasso that is not in the true model why
can that be
well assume that x1 happens to be very
correlated with why
in this sense that it is a good
expression of
what the what the combination of x2 and
x3 is that really matters for the
outcome
this may be a little bit artificial but
in very high dimension we can see all
kinds of correlations
so in this case x1 alone would be a
better predictor than
x2 alone or x3 alone but including both
x3 and x
x2 may be very costly and therefore the
lasso may prefer to just include the one
variable that
is correlated with both x2 and x3
explains both reasonably well
rather than including any of the true
variables
beyond what is included there can also
be biases in size
so assume x3 is not selected that
doesn't mean
that the variable x2 is correctly
represented
specifically by excluding x3
the lasso will also bias the coefficient
on x2
through omitted variable bias so we are
aware
that there can be biases in linear
regression when we omit certain
variables
what the lasso does is by excluding
it actively encourages or generates
omitted variable bias
so in that case the lasso decides not to
include a certain variable because
another highly correlated variable is
included that automatically will create
omitted variable bias
in the variable that is still included
even if x2 and x3 are selected there
will still be
some bias by shrinking the coefficients
towards zero
so even then there will be some
shrinkage bias but that i think is
typically second order
to the committed variable bias which may
be more misleading than simply shrinking
towards zero
so in high dimensions i would say that
such correlations
can happen a lot and therefore we always
have to be aware
that such biases can happen and we
should be very careful
with interpreting now rich may be
slightly better behaved because it
doesn't include things
but rich can also have biases so let's
recall what ridge does
ridge is socialist in nature
it tends to smooth out the coefficients
because it penalizes
very high coefficients by penalizing the
sum of squares of those coefficients
in that case the bias as we can see
we can see in a simple example just two
variables
x1 and x2 let's assume the outcome only
depends on x2
in that case we can actually explicitly
write what
the coefficient on x1 and x2 will be as
a function of the correlation between
x1 and x2 as well as a function
of the of the regularization parameter
here i'm for simplicity assuming that
there's no noise whatsoever
so what happens here here i have two
kinds of biases
the first is an expansion bias meaning
that
the rich regression puts weight on x1
despite
x1 actually not mattering for y
whenever x1 and x2 are correlated
because it tends to be socialist
and smooths things out at the same time
there can be shrinkage bias where the
coefficient
on x2 is therefore lower so in that case
we could see a regression where it looks
like x1 has quite some effect
but that is really because of ridge and
regularization and not because
x1 has a true effect
this behavior is not restricted
to linear regression type estimators
for example we could repeat something
similar
by looking at the trees that get
selected when we fit a regression tree
and just look at what are the variables
that get selected in the top trees in a
small tree
and what we will see there is something
similar and this is just for
illustration i don't think it's like the
the cleanest example for anything
really but just showing that you know
when i just look at the top variables
chosen by the two you're sure again
there are some
ones that get um selected quite
frequently
like this one here on top but a lot of
them
um get selected sometimes but not that
often
so same thing just looking at a tree is
unlikely to tell us something
about the true underlying stable
relationship
just witnessed by the fact that it
changes a lot
from draw to draw so
what is my takeaway from all this
my takeaway is that we should
distinguish carefully
not just between the methods we use but
also between
the questions that these methods try to
answer
specifically i want to distinguish
between two goals here
one is the goal of prediction where we
care about out of sample loss
minimization
and the other is the goal of estimation
where we care about
inference on coefficients and finding
out which of the x's specifically
affects y
so in high dimensions we can still be in
a world we can have good predictions
even when the coefficients are unstable
by inconsistent estimation is hard
but because in big data many functions
that look quite different can have
similar prediction properties
it will be very hard to distinguish
between those and therefore it will be
very hard
to perform good estimation so my big
takeaway here is that the very features
meaning the complexity the
regularization and the tuning that
machine learning brings in
that make predictions so successful also
make estimation hard
because they make it much harder to
understand coefficients well
they make it harder to interpret them
well because of bias
and they make it harder to interpret
them well also because we do data driven
tuning
which actually makes inference
considerably harder
therefore my big takeaway here is that
machine learning
is amazing at why i had problems at
problems that are about finding good
predictions
but it's not by itself built to solve
beta hat problems
or problems that are about doing
inference on parameters
so just to clarify what i mean by those
terms when i say machine learning does
prediction
and kind of linear regression type
estimation
is having a different goal so what i
mean by prediction is that
of course in one way machine learning is
not great at prediction
it's not necessarily great at prediction
and
what would happen if i
used an alternative policy which is
inherently a causal inference question
so
i don't mean the kind of what would
happen if prediction or the what will
happen tomorrow if something has changed
what i mean by prediction is really not
this kind of factual that requires
structural or cause knowledge but it is
the question can i get a good fit
of y hat to y on data from the same
distribution so it's really saying
prediction
holding the distribution constant on the
other hand when i look at instant
estimation and i say it's not great at
estimation of course in one sense
machine learning is great at estimation
it's great at
approximating the optimal prediction
function well
with minimal loss however this loss is
prediction loss
it doesn't really tell us much about the
difference in parameters it only tells
us something about the difference
in terms of whether this set of
parameters produces different
predictions or not
so when i say that machine learning is
not created estimation
i really mean it's not great at
something like estimation consistency
meaning the coefficient is close to the
other coefficient
in a norm that is not implied by
prediction
so taking all this together here are my
takeaways for i'd work
machine learning provides high quality
predictions why had
but the while the prediction quality
comes with guarantees from the holdout
so for example i'm able to say it
predicts as
at least that much with some statistical
uncertainty
there's typically no guarantees about
the quality of estimation
and no estimation consistency or at
least estimation consistency meaning the
coefficient converging to the true
coefficient getting very close to the
coefficient is much harder to establish
than prediction consistency
hence by itself when we look at machine
learning output
we should not interpret it structurally
or even causally in a sense of how
are the x's related to the y's but we
should take it as what it is which is a
great predictor
as a side note it is also very hard to
do
inference on this f hat because in many
of the machine learning methods they're
very complex they use data-driven tuning
so it's very hard to use tools like the
bootstrap and the bootstrap may
typically fail
so simply saying well couldn't i just
have bootstrapped this and seen that the
last is unstable it's not that easy
because the lasso doesn't typically
fulfill the kind of conditions
under which we know that the bootstrap
works
so therefore where can we use machine
learning
i'm a big fan of machine learning i
think it provides very good predictions
so in my eyes
the right answer to that is we should
use it for prediction problems
and ask where are interesting prediction
problems and here are some cases
first of all we could use machine
learning or we can use machine learning
as already done
for data pre-processing for example
using
text data using image data
simplifying very complex data to the
most important components
all this can often be cast as a
prediction component
for example i can predict whether
you know i can predict crop yield or
economic outcomes from
satellite image data and then use
satellite images
in place of the data to construct good
proxies a second big area
is tasks that are actually inherently
prediction tasks meaning tasks where
prediction is
an interesting question of interest and
these have also been coined
as prediction policy problems and one
good example would actually be poverty
targeting
in the case of poverty targeting i'm
interested in understanding
who which household likely
has low consumption so that i know which
household to help
and and in that case we could cast this
as a prediction problem where it's
really not about
understanding of course of course it's
also interesting understanding what
what leads to a household having low
consumption but in the end for the
poverty targeting question of just
where should i send help it may be most
important to simply have a good
prediction
and i think there are a whole host of
questions
in that area host of problems in that
area that are pure prediction problems
third there are many questions where we
care about parameters in some
part of the problem but there may be
some implicit prediction problems in the
background
something like using high dimensional
variables as
control variables using them for
propensity scores
using high dimensional instruments and
in
the next part of our webinar series
my colleague susan athey will
specifically talk about ways in which we
can combine those two
in which we can enhance causal inference
by using
tools and techniques and ideas for
machine learning
in order to enhance them which will
often require
to carefully adapt machine learning to
the specific task at hand
rather than just using it out of the box
so with that let me wrap up for the
webinar that i presented
here is what i did i first motivated
this by this webinar by saying machine
learning is amazing at prediction and
also
prediction solutions actually provide a
lot of value in modern
machine intelligence tasks second
i ask the question how we can get good
predictions
and what machine learning does to get
there in other words
i asked the question how can we get good
y hats
and in this last part i compared getting
good y heads
to getting good beta hats or in other
words getting good
estimation and i
derived as a takeaway that machine
learning is great at getting
high quality y hats but by itself
doesn't deliver
good beta hats or good estimation
and with that i want to
thank you for following the webinar
i would very much appreciate your
feedback if there were particular parts
that you liked that you found helpful
or especially if there were some parts
that you didn't like as much or
had a hard time following please shoot
me an email and let me know
so that we can improve those webinars in
the future thank you